طيب كيف تردون على المخاوف التي عبر عنها
الكثير من المراقبين والملاحظين خاصه من
خارج ايطاليا لفوز حزب افرتيل ايطاليا
بان اخوه ايطاليا
هي قوه امسيه تحكم مع قوتنا السياسيه
وديرها هي جزء من الاغلبيه
هو حزب ديمقراطيون بافكار واضحه وبالتاكيد
هي افكار متتاليه
الدستوريه
والديمقراطيه لبلادنا وقد اظهر هذا الحزب
تصميما وسعوده لم ياتي من فراغ بل رفيعه
كيس الاراده الشعبيه الحاليه ورؤيه جزء
معتبر من الايطاليين الى كيف يمكن وانتظر
حياتهما اليوميه وكيف ينبغي ان تكون
اداراتهم السياسيه لكن للاسف في الكثير من
المناسبات وليس فقط لايطاليا وانما الكثير
من الاحزاب من يمين الوسط تم استبعادها
بشكل الرئيسي من قبل التيار يساري الوسط
في بلدنا وحتى على المستوى الدولي وقد
روميل وكانهم دخلوا وعن المشهد السياسي او
خارجي ايطالي المبادئ الديمقراطيه وهذا
خطا كبير
قد يتميز هذا الحزب عن تيار يساري الوسط
فيما يتعلق به نظرته بشكل الوطن وذلك حقه
الشرعي وحق الجميل مدام يمارسون العمليه
السياسيه في اطارها القانوني والديمقراطي
لكنني لن اسمح لنفسي ابدا ان افقد خصم
السياسي شرعيته وان انعته بانه غير
ديمقراطيه او ان اتجاوز الحدود بشانه
بامكانه الاعتراض على مواقفهم اذا لم
اوافقوا معي حتى بقوه لكن دائما ضمن
الاحترام للمتبادل للقوه السياسيه في
الساحه وفي ظل احترامي اراده الشعب التي
تترجم من خلال الانتخابات